That's right. The times when he is forced to use his power
are the most exhilarating parts in this anime.
The number of abilities he can use is limitless.
Ta-da!
Hi, it's N-ko!
This week's The N-ko Show has started.
It has been really hot lately.
When it's hot, to make myself feel cool from the inside,
I eat a lot of food
that is in season in summer, like vegetables and fruits.
For example, I absolutely love somen noodles.
Somen noodles are very thin, white, er…
noodles.
(Usually eaten chilled)
I would cut rolled omelet into thin strips,
and julienne cucumbers,
and I love eating it with ginger and Japanese ginger.
To my surprise, many foreign people can't slurp noodles,
so when I have somen noodles with friends from foreign countries,
I would give them a lecture on how to slurp noodles.
It's so hot now,
so let's eat a lot of food that will make the body feel cool from the inside.
Well then, let's start this week's The N-ko Show!
Weekly Favorites!
I will share my recommendations based on my personal preference again.
This is the theme.
It's perfect in summer!
Exhilarating Anime!
Everyone, what is the thing you want when summer comes?
Hmm, ice cream?
Sea bathing.
A cool, well air-conditioned room.
All right.
So to answer to your requests,
I'll recommend anime that will make you feel refreshed just by watching them.
This is the first one.
CELLS AT WORK!
It personifies cells that make up the human body,
and the anime depicts how the cells work for the body every day.
Although it's our own bodies,
we don't have many chances to realize what our cells do for us.
But in this anime, the cells themselves are personified,
the work and the roles played by each kind of cell
are replaced by scenes that are like parts of our daily life,
so it's an anime that's easy to understand, and educational.
What makes this anime exhilarating is
the process of cells killing things
that are harmful to our body, like viruses and bacteria.
Influenza, heatstroke, cancer cells…
They are risks that might happen to us.
Seeing how the cells continue to fight bravely with them
is very exhilarating.
After you finish watching the anime,
it makes you want to first thank your cells for working for you,
and you'll unconsciously eat and drink something healthier than usual.
You can learn about your own body in this anime,
and it's exhilarating, so I recommend it.
Next, it's this one.
THAT TIME I GOT REINCARNATED AS A SLIME.
Because of an unfortunate event,
Rimuru Tempest is reincarnated in a different world as a slime,
and he goes on an adventure with his friends in this anime.
Speaking of slimes,
they are the weakest monsters we're familiar with in RPG games.
Being reincarnated as a slime,
you may wonder about the protagonist's unfortunate circumstance,
but he has the power of defense that cancels attacks by the enemies,
the power of disguise,
and he can engulf an enemy and analyze them.
The number of abilities he can use is limitless.
The battles where he uses his many powers to defeat enemies
are very much worth watching.
To begin with, a slime is so weak,
so seeing one defeating enemies that are supposed to be stronger than him
is extremely exhilarating.
This anime takes advantage of the impression of slimes being the weakest,
please do watch it.
Last but not least, it's this one.
MOB PSYCHO 100.
The protagonist, Shigeo Kageyama possesses psychic power,
and people call him Mob.
He gets involved in various cases,
and the way he grows as a person is depicted
in this youth gag battle anime.
The psychic power Mob possesses is one of the world's most powerful,
but he wants a normal life so much,
that he never uses it eagerly.
His psychic power aside,
he sucks at sports and is troubled by love.
Being a dull, ordinary middle school student is one of his characteristics.
However, because his power is too strong,
cult groups and spirits gather around Mob.
That's right. The times when he is forced to use his power
are the most exhilarating parts in this anime.
Mob's face is usually unexpressive,
but the more excited he gets,
the closer his emotions come to exploding.
When his anger explodes, he is like a different person,
and the strongest Mob emerges.
By the way, Mob is surprisingly cool after his anger explodes,
and it's worth noting.
The anime I introduced today
are packed with parts that make you feel good and exhilarated,
so please do watch them.
That's it for Weekly Favorites.
N-ko English.
In this segment, I will share how to say anime quotes in English.
This time, I'll also share an anime quote you'll want to use
whenever you get the chance.
Well then, let's begin.
This is today's quote.
"It's okay to run away from things you don't want."
It's okay to run away from things you don't want.
Right before Mob's stress level rose to 100 percent,
Mob's mentor said that to him.
Mob's mentor is positive about running away from something he doesn't want,
his open-mindedness makes me have a crush on him.
A little tip on pronunciation.
Say "run away,"
pause a little and say,
"from things you don't want."
After you say "run away," pause a little,
then "from things you don't want."
The point is to stress that it's okay to run away,
so accentuate the "it's okay to run away" part,
then say, "from things you don't want."
If you say it like this,
I think it's going to make it sound cooler.
Please do try to use this quote.
That's it for N-ko English.
N-ko's Q & A!
I will answer your questions again this week.
Let's start.
This is the first question.
"If you had a whole day off,
would you be able to watch an entire anime in one day?"
Of course, I can.
I have done this before.
When I was quite little,
I was quite a weak lamb.
I was often sick and had to take days off from school.
Then I would watch anime throughout the day.
And I once had influenza when I was in college.
When I had the flu,
I got better in two, three days after I took medicine,
although I couldn't go to school for seven to ten days.
So I watched YU YU HAKUSHO during that time.
I watched the hundreds of episodes of the series in one go.
I am a sheep who quite likes watching a whole series in one go.
Okay, next question.
"What's some anime merchandise you've been wanting to get your hands on lately?
For me, it's been DRAGON BALL figurines."
In the past, it was figurines,
acrylic stands,
acrylic key holders.
I loved collecting those.
But I am 24 years old now,
and I am a grown-up sheep,
so now, it's something I can use in daily life,
something that uses an anime as the motif,
such as Blu-ray, DVD, and posters.
My interest in merchandise has shifted to those.
I sometimes buy T-shirts that don't look like anime T-shirts at a glance.
Or I would want posters that look stunning,
and I want to have luxurious boxes of Blu-ray or DVD.
Those are what I've been buying lately.
Okay, next question.
"If you appear in an anime, what story do you think it will be?"
I think it'd be kind of similar to AGGRETSUKO.
AGGRETSUKO is the story of an ordinary red panda working at an office.
I am also a sheep-human lifeform working at an office,
so it would be an anime that talks about my work.
I think it will be an anime about the daily life of a sheep office worker.
But if I were to become the protagonist of a fantasy anime,
maybe I'll fly in the sky
or possess some kind of mysterious power,
accompanied by a mysterious creature,
and do something in a mysterious world.
I want to become the protagonist of an anime full of elements of fantasy.
Okay, next question.
"Could you tell me why you have the sheep-form, N-ko?
What is the relationship between sheep and Netflix?"
I have the sheep-form because
I am a sheep-human lifeform.
This is the only answer I can give you.
If there's any relationship between sheep and Netflix,
it's just like how you count sheep before you sleep.
I hope you can open Netflix and enjoy its contents before you sleep.
I think it's also what I wished for,
with regard to the relationship between me and Netflix.
Okay, next question.
Someone said they are curious about the names of my pets.
The names of my dogs are Lucky, Lulu, Leo, Luke, and Hana-chan.
The names of my cats are a little complicated.
They have two names, the real name and a nickname.
I call them their nicknames more often than their real names.
Genpachi and Shino are their real names,
their nicknames are Beibei and Bibi.
My sugar glider's name is Teto,
my chinchilla's name is Yona.
Those are the names of my pets.
Thank you for your various questions this time, too.
I'm still waiting for you to send me your questions.
That's it for N-ko's Q & A.
The N-ko Show! It's now time to say goodbye.
Today's theme has been "feeling exhilarated."
I think we want to feel refreshed every day in summer.
The other side of an automatic door is often cool.
So like how an air-conditioned space can make you feel refreshed,
I hope you're going to find something
that makes you feel refreshed in your daily life.
So the thing I'll do before next week.
I think there are many more exhilarating anime in the world,
so I'll continue to look for their exhilarating elements
when I watch the anime.
Let's meet again next time!
See you!